after nine years of dominating north
america
doublelift has retired from professional
league of legends
and this news came just a day before tsm
signed sword art in a move which looks
set to make him
the highest paid player in north
american
history where does doublelift go next
what do these moves mean for tsm this
might be
the craziest offseason of all time
all right we've got a lot to get through
in this video i'm going to dive right
into it
after i ask you to hit the subscribe
button if you haven't done so already
we're on the road to 2 million subs
we're very excited so if you haven't
subscribed
please help us get there so on wednesday
doublelift added
yet another page into what has been a
crazy
offseason for the lcs by announcing he
is retiring after
nine years of professional play many in
the community were shot
sad or just straight up heartbroken at
the news
bear in mind doublelift has more fans
than some
teams do voyboy called him the goat of
na
perks who recently made headlines with
his move to c9
made a tongue-in-cheek remark about him
being a hero of both
na and eu former teammate svenskaran
simply said he was the best player he'd
had the chance to play with
while azale remarked that along with
bjerg's retirement
it really felt like the end of an era
travis gafford let doublelift stay with
him when he was
homeless and trying to keep his early
pro career
alive naturally he was one of the first
to share his thoughts
i'm going to miss creating that content
with him
interviewing him celebrating his
victories and
you know suffering in his defeats even
the league of legends
subreddit temporarily changed its name
to the league of doublelift in his honor
he truly is the face of the north
american league and it's gonna be
really strange watching an lcs where
he's not competing
every week that said fans barely had a
chance to gather their thoughts because
on thursday tsm announced what may be
the biggest contract in north american
history
hello everyone i'm sword art i'm the new
support for tsm
now sword art joining tsm is obviously
huge news but the big question is will
it transform
tsm despite winning the last split in
true
anime style there were big questions
about what a bjergsen list tsm would
actually look like coupled with the
star-studded roster that cloud9
and team liquid have put together and it
looked like tsm were really going to
have their work cut out if they wanted
to retain their lcs title but soda
is arguably in the top five supports on
the planet
the taiwanese star is a fresh world
finalist who drew a lot of praise
for his ruthless aggression during
sunning's journey to the finals and if
it wasn't for dam 1 gaming
playing on an almost super human level
sword art would probably be deciding
which world champion skin he wants right
about now and let me tell you
he certainly thinks he has what it takes
to fix the issues that have
dogged tsm for years i think tsm
have very good talent but sometimes they
take too long time to end the game so i
want to bring
some lpl style to tsm to make tsm
play more aggressive and then we can
make every game very
interesting and also make lcs stronger
the deal is reportedly worth an
eye-watering 6
million dollars speaking to the
washington post
tsm owner reggie feels like this is
worth it stating
my investment thesis is that teams that
win build dollars down the road
teams that create a legacy and a large
fan base and consistency of
winning it just makes sense for tsm to
spend these dollars to recruit players
so doublelift is out and sword art is in
if that was the whole story it might be
kind of simple
but tsm's offseason has been far from
straightforward
in fact it's been pretty chaotic so
first it looked like doublelift was
staying
then it looked like sword art was going
to join him in the bot lane
then it looked like he wasn't then it
looked like he was and then
doublelift retired let's jump back to
last year when things look good for
doublelift and tsm
it took some serious comebacks and an
absolute bjergsen
masterclass to drag the team to the
summer 2020 finals
where they took down flyquest to win the
title turtle the same
but doublelift has always been the
better 80 carry
shows it here in the game as the nexus
falls
tsm claim lcs title number seven
even the most die-hard tsm fans didn't
expect this to happen but tsm
had done it they had won and now they
were finally back at worlds after
three years unfortunately the fairy tale
ended at worlds 2020
in fact it wasn't just ended it was
smashed
pulverized scraped off the ground and
punched in its stupid fairy tale face
i don't want to be like negative after
we just
lost out of whales but we really like
throughout the boot camp we forgot to
play the game
tsm fans begged the league of legends
gods for mercy and the god
said lol no bjergsen retired after
worlds and moved to the head coach
position for the team bjergsen had been
either double his teammate
or his opponent for the past five years
and the news clearly got him thinking
yeah that's what i thought to you oh
yeah that's one thing like i was like
writing my retirement speech
for a few days and uh i was thinking
about wow it's crazy you know if me and
soren both retire how crazy is that
going to be for lcs
the speculation about doublelift's
retirement continued until the free
agency window
opened it was rumored that tsm were
picking up
huni power of evil and sword art then
jacob wolf reported there was a
problem tsm were reportedly struggling
to nail down
sword art because of immigration and
payment issues doublelift reportedly
wanted
a top tier foreign support and if they
couldn't get sword up
he might not want to play for them
travis gafford would later joke that it
felt like a tsm
fan had used a monkey poor to wish for
the 2020 summer split win
so this whole speculation about
doublelift's retirement flared up yet
again
and i will dominate broke down what
might be going through doublelift's head
speak a power of evil double if like i
don't think that team's going to win a
championship like
and giving another full season to not
win a championship i think he's just too
detrimental at this point in his career
like it just
there's no point you're better off
retiring than like
grinding a full year for a mediocre um
finish and potentially just to like
devalue your own legacy so it seemed
like it was all
resting on this sword art deal if tsm
could secure sword art
then doublelift would stay the deal had
looked dead in the water ever since
jacob wolf's tweet
but then on tuesday there were whispers
that it might have been
saved when sooning announced that sword
art was leaving the team
as everyone was speculating about
whether this meant the deal was back on
wednesday came and doublelift dropped
the bomb that he was retiring
i mean it was getting crazy at this
point if doublelift was supposed to stay
if tsm secured sword art
then did him retiring mean that sword
art wasn't happening
finally an answer came on thursday when
tsm announced that sword art
would be joining the team the washington
post had reported a few hours earlier
that the deal would be worth
6 million over two years if this
is true it would blow other record
signings
out of the water dignitas signing huni
for 2.3
million dollars and even c9 signing
perks
would fall short of this number
according to jacob wolf so there you
have it
two of the biggest moves of the
offseason sword art is now
n a bound and doublelift has left the
rift doublelift
is an eight-time lcs champion
five-time lcs all-star five-time member
of the all-pro first team and msi
finalist for someone that was
memed on for having an empty trophy case
for so
many years it's looking pretty full as
he finally bows out for years now
doublelift's goal
was to do well at worlds for all his
accomplishments he never
actually made it out of group stage at
worlds so now you have to ask
what's his goal an educated guess would
be that he moves to streaming
that's what he did when he took a split
off in 2017 and it went really well
he pulled in some serious numbers maybe
i'm way off the mark here and he's gonna
go into coaching
i don't know all i know is that
doublelift has always enjoyed subverting
expectations
as for tsm despite all the back and
forth over the past few weeks and
despite signing
sword art we still don't have a
confirmed starting roster for them yet
it's the off season that just keeps on
giving folks
and i'm sure there's plenty more twists
to come
when it comes to the confirmed roster
like what their lineup's going to be
huni is that still happening i mean by
the time this video goes out that might
be confirmed yeah there was a little bit
of concern about huni
because there was like the whole deal
with eg for lost and now it looks like
lost isn't going to eg
so does that mean they're not going to
give up huni but that might still be
okay
uh we know speaker's staying we know
we've got power power of evil
um uh doublelift is gone so yeah he's
been replaced by lost
sword art it looks like it's close to
being confirmed
um you know tsm might be the last team
in north america i think to actually
confirm their whole lineup
but we'll get there we'll get there